I think we have to be realistic about
technology technology is not necessarily
a good thing or a bad thing it's like
money is not a good thing or a bad thing
it's how we use it and there must be
balance of all technologies that we're
talking about can support relationships
but they can't replace them it's like
when Facebook became a thing you know it
doesn't replace the relationship but it
allows us to maintain relationships
internationally for example or stay up
to date with what friends are doing when
we don't talk to them every day but if
we only rely on digital relationships
then we actually increase loneliness and
so Ai and and those new technologies are
the same we have to be open about it
that we're using these things for
transactional things if you need
something transactional the the AI can
help you but both of us I'm sure would
hate to interact with AI when we're
struggling when we're worried when we're
scared then I need a human being who has
empathy for me even if the AI says the
same things I need a person to feel what
I'm feeling and that's what creates
trust so I think technology and the rise
of AI is perfectly legitimate for day to
day
um and make time so that we have more
time to actually build deep meaningful
relationships some jobs will be erased
of course but new jobs will emerge as
well I mean we talk now technologists
love to talk about how 80 of the jobs
that exist today didn't exist 30 years
ago well it'll be the same I think a
good analogy is travel agents you know
when the rise of Wikipedia and
Travelocity and an online booking
everybody predicted that travel agents
would be dead and and we have no use for
them anymore turns out there's tons of
demand for for travel agents they call
themselves travel advisors now because
people want a human relationship to help
them book a trip and who understand
their family not simply just buy tickets
it's the same thing you know technology
allows somebody to just trade stocks or
buy bonds if they want but not somebody
who can understand and help them manage
a complicated system especially when
we're not sophisticated Financial people
ourselves very very sophisticated people
like to do it themselves but most of us
aren't like that so I think the human
relationship is here to stay